so the point of view of a criminal how
would that be shown differently it would
just be within the actions within the
mind I mean it just seems like both are
gonna be very methodical criminals are
very smart are usually very intuitive
you know and there's a fine line
sometimes because both sides yeah it
won't go into that topic but but would
they still be very meticulous in their
actions or would they mean more sloppy
and that's why some are caught Oh
my favorite topic organized versus
disorganized offenders we have a word
for it our name a phrase organized would
be Ted Bundy very easily he just give
you a real example very bright men he
actually took his own not his own life
he took his he took his own life
hit control of his own courtroom yeah
and he defended himself the right before
he sentenced him the judge looked him
straight in the eye and said sir I would
love to have you practice in my
courtroom and it's something along the
lines of however you're sick disgusting
man and you're going to die it was a
very powerful moment very powerful but
but back to he's an organized defender
things were very neat his crime scenes
were very clean there's very little
evidence many times his crime scene was
different than his dump site the crime
scene being where all and murder the
murder actually happened would be the
crime scene or the scene of the crime
whereas a dump site would be where you
find the body in Silence of the Lambs
they were finding them in rivers and
thing and lakes and things like that
so that was not the crime scene he
didn't kill him in the river he killed
him elsewhere and as we find out later
he kills him spoiler alert he kills them
in there in his basement and then
disposes of the bodies interesting the
reason I love that book so much and it
is my favorite book is a red dragon
soundless Atlantis is good too but he
amalgamates
Ted Bundy Theodore Kaczynski which is
the Unabomber maybe not him he
amalgamates about four or five traits of
serial killers Ed Gein with the
skin.that which Texas Chainsaw Massacre
was taken from taking way out of
proportion of course Zodiac killer the
Zodiac killer
yeah which may have been Theodore
Kaczynski actually so if you don't know
this this is just just a tidbit the
manifesto of the Zodiac killer the very
last segment they could not decipher but
if you put in Theodore Kaczynski it
finished it exactly yes it's I studied
weird things which is why which is why
we're here
you